rumor was right about the future of a
first minister
in my head and in my heart I know that
time is now
that it is right for me for my party and
for the country
and so today I am announcing my
intention to step down as first Minister
and leader of my party
outside supporters waited opponents
watched as Nicola sturgeon bowed out
after eight years at the helm
[Applause]
leaving at a time of a legal standoff
with Downing streets over the Scottish
government making it easier to change
gender something UK ministers are
blocking I am trying to rationally
individually what I'm trying to do is
address the issues quitting amid an
awkward period after it's emerged a
double rapist was housed temporarily in
a woman's prison this decision comes
from a deeper and longer term assessment
do you believe though that the issues
are and particularly the row around
transgender prisoners was the straw that
broke the camel's back here it's not the
case that this decision is because of
short-term issues I've faced more
short-term issues from time to time over
my years in politics than I care to
remember
um and if it was just that I wouldn't be
standing here today Nicola sturgeon may
be saying publicly that the last few
weeks have not been the deciding factor
but this major rival over gender reforms
has been incredibly challenging her main
mission of securing Independence during
her Premiership has failed and it's
unclear if or even when a second vote
here in Scotland may happen pull all of
those factors together and it's easier
to see why now the first Minister thinks
it may be time for fresh blood
the snps hope to lead Scotland to a
different future was dealt a hammer blow
when the Supreme Court ruled Hollywood
could not legally hold a second vote
should have expected having set her
course for this de facto referendum with
all the difficulties it entails that
that's the one you would you would see
through and you'd often expect no
challenges happen in politics so the the
independence movement has been led to no
idea then but certainly a roadblock and
her successor and others in Scotland
will have to to find a way through it
and the search for that successor is now
underway to replace a formidable Force
the figurehead of a movement who's now
preparing for life away from the top job
Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh